on the political stage he can be
magnetic much like when he is performing
his music for funds but Bobby wine says
his entertainment career is being
curtailed more than 15 of my concerts
after the Challenger concert have been
canceled by the police the promoters
that are organizing my concerts have
been advised to stop working with me so
that they can be allowed to work on
December 15th Bobby one tweeted that
police had attempted to block him from
performing a show in the town of ginger
he managed to escape arrest and later
give his account of what happened to GW
it was 8 o clock in the night when the
police raided the hotel with the army
started beating people and arresting
people three of my people were arrested
some kind people helped me to elude them
and I disappear from that place and they
looked for me the entire night but could
not see me Bobby Wayne believes the
police don't want him performing his
music shows as he's using them as an
opportunity to make political statements
when the government was asked to respond
to the claims
Uganda's security minister answered in
Parliament
and what I can say if you allow me to
continue I will say these are special
hazards
bubbly wine wine a seat in the Ugandan
Parliament in 2017 this followed more
than 15 successful years as a musician a
Correa he has refused to give up I'm not
quitting music whatsoever I am going to
continue singing my music and I'm going
to continue organizing my concerts when
the police continuously blocked me from
excel from practicing my poll profession
from feeding my family they are
continuously exposing themselves in
August Bobby wine was arrested at a
political rally and reportedly protested
he was later charged with treason Bobby
wine has been a fierce critic of
President Yoweri Museveni who's been in
power for more than 30 years